white house is supposedly haunted
the ghost of abraham lincoln is supposed
to roam the white house he's been
spotted by
the
eleanor roosevelt queen of the
netherlands and winston churchill queen
of the other ones opened her door and he
was standing there and she fainted
and winston churchill got out of a hot
bath and he was had nothing but a cigar
and he walked into his room and lincoln
was standing there
and he tapped the ashes in the cigar and
said good evening mr president you seem
to have caught me at a disadvantage
lincoln smiled softly and then
disappeared
well that's i would believe the other
one more than a big one churchill i
think you were
drunk